-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#homecomingfail stories
from you guys.
This first one's
from @StevecarlsonWF.
He says, "I nervously asked
the girl I liked,
'Do you want to go
to homecoming?'
When she said yes,
I was still so nervous
that for some reason, I blurted
out, 'Cool. With who?'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I-I-I'm just doing a survey.
I want to know
who's going with who."
This one's from @boobearmelly.
She says, "Nelly's song
'Get Your Eagle On' was playing.
I dropped down so low,
my pants split down the middle.
All my friends
had to huddle around me
and dance me out of the gym."
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
I mean, that's what
friends are for, man.
That's what friends are for.
This one's from @airmailbird.
She says,
"My friend's dad rented a limo
for him and his homecoming date,
but he was also their chauffeur
and gave them 'The Talk'
on the way there."
-Oh!
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
Oh.
-"When a man and woman
love each other..."
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @dackjaniels.
-Nice.
Not Jack Daniels.
Dack Janiels, man.
-Dack Janiels.
I get it.
He says,
"I only knew one dance move
that I learned
from an M.C. Hammer music video,
and I danced that
one move all night.
My date asked
if I knew anything else,
so I tried
an impromptu spin move
and accidentally
slapped her in the face."
[ Laughter ]
This guy's a disaster!
[ Sad trombone ]
Go home.
That is a fail.
-Mr. Janiels.
-Yeah.
This one's from @MCDani9214.
She says,
"My date really loved the song
'You're Beautiful,'
by James Blunt.
When it came on,
he said he needed to
feel this one on his own
and went to a corner
and danced with himself."
[ Laughter ]
"You're Beautiful"?
-What?
-♪♪ You're beautiful ♪♪
♪♪ You're beautiful ♪♪
-Can I be blunt?
[ Light laughter ]
-This one's from
@burninglegacies.
-Ooh.
[ Light laughter ]
-She says, "Our homecoming
had a low budget,
so we got an elderly deejay
who played songs off youtube.
We spent half the dance
waiting for ads to be over."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
"I like this Geico ad."
-"Yeah."
-"Pretty good."
-"Hold on a second."
-This last one's from @VIPrice.
He says, "My mom
chaperoned our homecoming.
She showed up a little tipsy
and ended up
leading the whole school
in doing the 'Thriller' dance."
There you have it.
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Check out more of our favorites.
Go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.